well I don't think that Britain is a
very good indication of what's happening
in to religion worldwide what is
happening is that all sorts of conflicts
that we would want have described as
ethnic or communal or might have been
ideological economic whatever uh now
seem speedy in most respects religious
so what we're seeing in the Middle East
is a conflict between Sunni and Shiah
but but one of the things that I thought
was very interesting about your piece
and that actually I think is even more
serious than then you account for is the
way that Britain's foreign policy in
particular is completely unable to cope
with religious conflicts you know
William Hague understands Brangelina he
sure does not look like he understands
boca rom I think person at university
may he he was never aged in religion
then he distinction between Islam and
Islamism as we call it is in many ways a
false one because we assume the ordinary
law-abiding members of a religion are
utterly opposed to violence its actual
violence or violent rhetoric on their
behalf and they're not Oh Christine
O'Donnell and she's jumping ask you
there what do you make of Damian's
characterization of the Islamic world in
this piece I can just see Damian in the
Middle Ages thinking ah Christians there
are Crusaders and that's the same
mistake that you make with Muslims
they're not all Islamists and didn't you
say they were no but but you do you do
you knew that you're not Douglass Mary
but you do fall into this you know Islam
is a religion of violence and it's a
religion where you know the jihad is you
know no it isn't I mean I think the
great majority of Muslim British
citizens are not gagging to go out
eventually and if ITIF I taught religion
Islam as a religion of violence I would
have said so in a PSA but let's bring it
back to our own guilt here yeah by
quashing any kind of faith inspired
institution as much as it can this very
secularist establishment and I I would
include the government there has has
really given pause for thought to a lot
of Muslims Christians and Jews who feel
completely disenfranchised and I'm not
saying that that means that they will go
and pick up a dagger or though picked up
a Kalashnikov but they do feel a little
bit of sympathy for those of their own
who go out there and take a stand for
our ignorance our hostility because it's
more than ignorance it's a kind of
Richard Dawkins style hostility to
religion is giving us a bad name across
the world and especially among those
countries where belief is a fundamental
part of their everyday existence we are
discredited in the eyes of many Muslim
countries out of many Buddhist countries
and our many Catholic countries yeah I
don't see it quite like that I think
that you know the middle-aged people in
governments are not religious themselves
and they make enormous the pious noises
and then they were backwards to
accommodate people who as you say they
don't really understand therefore in the
process actually making I think the
problem worse but if you look at people
in the people in their 20s tonight
they asked for the young that's
important people in their twenties what
their religious belief is always nearly
always say atheist which was a word that
was you know who was it was a slight to
me to move twenty or thirty years ago I
think we're talking it actually reflects
you and it really does reflect uh partly
the fact that the young much upon elite
the people who will be running the world
the Western world in in ten years time
have no significant religious belief